hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 10 of the Republic Plato through
the mouthpiece of Socrates makes an
extended argument about whether homer
and by extension any of the poet's any
of the people who work in the medium of
language and create whether dramatic
productions epic lyric productions
whether any of them possess genuine
knowledge about the the things that
they're discussing or whether they have
merely the semblance of knowledge which
makes them a bit dangerous as guides for
anything that we would want to take
their advice on and this is a real live
issue because if you look in Homer's
Iliad or in Homer's Odyssey you will see
Homer himself at this point at that
point telling you how things are done
telling you who is a good person at this
art or discipline or skill and that this
person over here is not and he'll also
have the characters making speeches in
which they are conveying what what
appears to be knowledge on these topics
so you might think for example about the
Odyssey very early on there's an
assembly in Ithaca and Telemachus
Odysseus's son speaks at the Assembly he
lays out his complaints against the
suitor he's essentially engaged in
ethics and in political science and he's
telling the people of Ithaca what they
ought to be doing in relation to these
suitors so he's giving them practical
advice is Homer in portraying this
conveying to us any knowledge that's the
fundamental question and the kinds of
arts or disciplines or sciences that
Socrates brings up here are medicine you
know Homer talks about how people heal
other people strategy or generalship as
how it's sometimes translated
legislation or
statesmanship practical arts that that
produce things that are useful for us in
life a way of life a consistent ethics
you could say and then education more
generally Homer does in fact talk about
all of these and the ancient Greeks all
the way up till plato's time did think
that he was very convincing that Homer
was a reliable guide so they would make
reference to him and bring up quotes
from him and from other poets you'll see
this actually happening in platonic
dialogues as well not just on the part
of other characters but even on the part
of Socrates so the question here is is
there any legitimacy to this so how
would you determine that Plato in effect
gives us two criteria and a little bit
of backstory Plato has just laid out for
us the fact that these imitative artists
are further removed from reality than
craftspeople themselves who work with
you know material things and even they
are removed from the ideal archetypes or
patterns or forms that are most real
most true so in making a bed for example
the the bed maker the carpenter looks to
the ideal pattern that's somehow in his
mind makes a physical bed Homer writes
about Telemachus laying in a bed and
discusses the woolen blanket that he
pulls up over himself and whether a bet
is good or not
Homer is more removed from the reality
of the the single archetype of bed than
is the bed maker the carpenter and we
can say similarly for it for everything
else so all of that said the key thing
here is how do we know that the poets
don't really know what they're talking
about
well one criteria
is can they in fact do the sorts of
things can they produce the effect that
these people do does Homer actually heal
anybody does Homer actually produce a
way of life that we can follow another
criteria is whether other people looking
to the poet say AHA this person does
have knowledge we're going to Commission
them we're going to rely upon them to
provide us with these services as a
matter of fact Plato actually goes so
far as to say that if Homer or Hesiod or
any of these other poets really knew
what they were talking about nobody
would let them do poetry nobody who
allow them to spend the time writing
these poems composing these things in
their head
they'd make them do the actual thing
instead so let's look at these these
criteria notice another thing too with
every single one of these sets of skills
except for Strada strategy generalship
Plato actually brings up somebody who
you can say did in fact or does in fact
have display and use those skills to the
satisfaction of other people there is a
little bit of sketchiness involved with
bringing up Protagoras and Prodicus -
Sophists who are oftentimes being
criticized in other parts of the
Platonic dialogues but let's put that
aside for the moment so let's think
about medicine medicine is one of the
disciplines that grew up alongside of
philosophy and although certainly not as
advanced as the medicine that we know
today Hippocrates and people like that
were in fact able to produce some sort
of healing with with some people right
so there was some science to it and they
attribute it to a skip leus you know the
the god of medicine son of Apollo and
then the doctors who
after him and Plato says look they are
actually able to heal people at least in
some cases they can tell you what to eat
if you're feeling sick they can say that
you should have a hot bath or a cold
bath or no bath at all they can diagnose
what is wrong with you so they have some
genuine knowledge Plato says did anybody
ever go to Homer for being healed of
anything no well then presumably Homer
doesn't actually know about medicine
even though he talks about medicine so
he talks about it in an imitative way
but without knowledge
he doesn't talk well as a result and the
mere fact that people think that he does
is just a function of they're not
actually knowing what medicine consists
in who do you want to consult to see
whether the poet talks well about
medicine probably a doctor strategy did
anybody ever give Homer a command a
military post from which to exercise
power why not
the answer is of course no why didn't
they do that why didn't they do their
with many of the other poets who talked
about military affairs now we do have to
make some exceptions here Solon who's
talked about in terms of legislation he
writes poetry and he in fact writes
poetry about political matters
presumably you would say that he
actually does understand those matters
because he he was involved in them so he
might be an exception of this rule but
Homer himself is not being brought in as
a strategic or technical consultants
right so again lots and lots of
discussions even cool things like
strategies the Trojan horse right or if
we want to take the Odyssey how do you
kill a whole bunch of people who are in
your house trying to seduce your wife
and there's you know many more of them
than there are
how would you take them out you know
there's all sorts of discussions of
strategy in there but Plato would say
that they're not based on any sort of
genuine knowledge what about legislation
here Plato brings up three people two of
which we know quite a bit about in which
he talked about quite it quite often
like Kyrgyz and Solan like her guests
was the law giver to lakatamia
or Sparta as we know it right he is the
one who straightened them out at one
time he said this is the way we're going
to set up the laws Solan is the one who
is responsible for Athens in that way he
was not actually the first lawmaker but
the law is that they had in Athens were
not particularly good and so he
rearranged them and the way that you can
tell that he actually did the right
thing is both the rich and the many
didn't like the way the laws went
because they restrained them from doing
the things that they would like so Plato
says we can point to examples of people
who successfully gave good laws to
various Greek city-states Homer talks
about good laws he talks about how
places should be arranged I brought up
the example of the meeting at Ithaca
where Telemachus is trying to you know
get the the people of Ithaca all the
princes to bring their power to bear on
these suitors to get them to leave him
alone to stop frequenting his halls and
eating up all of his food and to abandon
their claims so presumably Homer doesn't
actually know what he's talking about or
if he does it's an imitation several
steps removed from the real real
legislation the real statesmanship
displayed by somebody at some time what
about practical arts what about types of
knowledge that help us do things here he
brings up Thalys you might say well
isn't he that everything is water guy
yes but the lace is also somebody who
observes the sky and engages in the very
beginnings of meteorology weather
prediction as a matter of fact we find
out that he was successful enough in
predicting a bumper crop of olives that
he bought up all the olive presses and
then charged people high prices to use
them when there was a great crop and
made a ton of money thereby and we might
include other people in here he has Anna
Anna Casas as well I can't remember
offhand what he would have associated
with him
but these are practical arts that are
supposed to help us in managing our
day-to-day affairs some people actually
do possess knowledge in that way of life
here he talks about Pythagoras why does
he bring up pythagoras pythagoras did
not just produce a philosophical
doctrine he actually gave to all of his
followers a way in which they ought to
live embodying that doctrine there were
admittedly some obscure points to that
there's endless discussion about why
they thought you shouldn't eat beans for
example but that was in fact part of
their their their way of life their way
of putting the philosophy into practice
and play dough rather jokingly says
listen
are there any homer followers are you
know even his best friend didn't really
follow his his advice about things
nobody is following a Homeric way of
life now you could say well what about
Hesiod you know works and days don't
people follow that and and the answer is
well if you read Hesiod's poem not Metis
ok but you could say perhaps there is a
coherent way of life being set out in
that but if we're restricting ourselves
to homer then this is a legitimate
criticism finally he talks about
education and this one we've got to be a
little bit careful with because these
are the Sophists this is a little bit
sketchy Plato says these
guys protégés sand protagonists are able
to convince other people that they ought
to give their sons to them for education
and that they can educate them about all
sorts of matters he doesn't actually
commit himself to the view that that
that protocol and Protagoras in fact do
in fact understand all things and if you
read other platonic dialogues you'll see
that he does not have quite such a rosy
picture of them but what can we draw
from this Homer can't actually convince
us the way that these two guys could to
turn our children over to him for their
education so you know point after point
after point why is Plato bringing up so
many examples because he wants to show
that really everything that you might
turn to Homer for Homer does not provide
you with any genuine knowledge but only
the imitation of an imitation of
knowledge he's several steps removed
from that so the upshot of this is that
we should not in fact trust the poets
for knowledge about things we might
extend this in our own time to think
about all sorts of other people who
similarly are treated as if they have
knowledge about things we might talk
about novelists or filmmakers or
musicians Plato would say all these are
imitative artists the mere fact that
somebody can make a movie about
mathematics does not mean that
mathematics actually works the way that
they depict it in the movie when you
know somebody has a love song and
they're saying you know I understand
that it's hard for us to get along
because we're so different but hey baby
opposites attract maybe you're better
off going to a psychologist than then
listening to the song and taking advice
from that so this has relevance in our
own time if we understand other people
as fitting in this you know mimetic
imitative producers that Plato places
the poets and
with it
you